aquí tenemos este dos por cuatro tercios
igual a ocho por espacio blanco los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo por ustedes mismos piensen
que es lo que debería ir en este espacio
en blanco asumiendo que ustedes ya lo
intentaron por su cuenta
veamos cómo resolverlo dos por cuatro
tercios podemos ver esto literalmente
como lo reescribimos aquí lo pego aquí
abajo dos por cuatro tercios es
exactamente lo mismo que tener dos x en
lugar de escribir cuatro tercios de
hecho lo voy a escribir como cuatro
tercios parece que dije lo mismo pero
bueno ahorita verán a qué me refiero
escribo un tercio más un tercio más un
tercio más un tercio esto es
literalmente si cada uno de estos es un
tercio pues van a ser cuatro tercios es
dos por cuatro tercios es igual a dos
por cuatro tercios literalmente cuatro
tercios ahora
pues esto va a ser igual voy a escribir
aquí abajo lo copiamos y pegamos para
ahorrar tiempo
y lo voy a pegar dos veces
aquí hay una un grupo de cuatro tercios
un tercio más un tercio más un tercio
más un tercio y otro grupo igual que lo
voy a acomodar acá y los vamos a sumar
esto es literalmente dos por cuatro
tercios vamos a sumar todo esto bueno
ahora que tenemos todos muchos tercios
pues vamos a contar los 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
8 tercios esto es igual y para que quede
bien claro lo que estoy haciendo voy a
quitar los paréntesis porque finalmente
estamos sumando todos los tercios que
tenemos aquí estos paréntesis ya vienen
sobran quitamos éstos y así muestro que
literalmente lo que estoy haciendo es
son más todos estos tercios que es lo
mismo que tener 8 tharsis quitamos este
quitamos este otro muy bien ahora sí ya
está y espero que para ustedes esté
claro de que estos son ocho tercios esto
es igual
por un tercio ocho por un tercio un
tercio y aquí hemos respondido nuestra
pregunta dos por cuatro tercios es igual
a 8 por y acabamos de encontrar que esto
es un tercio y esto lo acabamos de ver
que también es literalmente ocho tercios
lo puedo escribir también como 8 entre
38 tercios lo ponemos en otro color para
que se vea bien 8 entre 3